we're so glad you could join us for this
our $100,000,000 season when we'll pass
a huge milestone and give away a grand
total of a hundred million dollars your
season yeah my fourth year to be doing
it but the new season premiere today
what is going to be different the
biggest thing is it's a 100 million
dollar season so we have given away 100
million dollars over the 17 year history
of the show
which is pretty amazing it all
culminates in November when we have this
big week-long celebration we we show a
bunch of clips of like your favorite
contestants over the last two decades
and we we choose one of them to actually
come back and play again yes : something
that is really it no matter what we say
we said Jason if we said you know Blake
it doesn't matter there's gonna be
backlash that's the way social media
works these days
Kohn's going to be good TV and that is
the reason we chose him it's not an
indictment by the way on Blake on Jason
on anybody else it's just that at the
end of the day the powers that be decide
Colton is going to be a good story good
TV he looks like The Bachelor he
probably won't have his shirt on after
night one so it's going to be a good
season I don't know and I think that's
going to be part of the beauty of this
of the journey and of the show is that
is ready he says he is he thinks he is
but is he and I think that's the whole
point of the show is that we're gonna
find out and by the way maybe at the end
of it he's not and it's a complete
disaster that's the way it goes that's
life that's kind of the beauty of the
show
[Music]
what advice do you have well this year I
bought because I know he's the bachelor
I brought in props so there's going to
be a big presentation of what happens in
the fantasy suite 3d models it's read
really gets interesting and I'm gonna
bring my son in as well who's a teenager
so I can knock out the talk and the talk
with Colton is just an evil no but it's
part of the storyline is the fact that
Colton's a bird's leg clearly how will
the women react to that how is he going
to handle that it's something he's
obviously dealt with his entire life
and he got emotional about it about when
he was in the NFL and having to fake it
with Tosh so we are going to deal with
that we'll dive into that
[Music]